is your property yours not if government
takes it and it can for what it calls
public use eminent domain law has long
allowed politicians to grab your
property to build roads railroad tracks
border walls which helps explain why
President Trump told Bret Baier
I think eminent domain is wonderful I
get it that a highway or a border wall
is public use but 13 years ago the
Supreme Court ruled that New London
Connecticut could bulldoze this little
pink house to make room for a new
business development eminent domain they
can take your home they can take your
land in this soon-to-be released movie
Catherine Keener places that kilo the
owner of that little pink house here
learning that she has no right to her
own property how could somebody break
into my house and take everything I have
and go to jail oh you could shoot oh
shoot oh I didn't tell them but if they
want the whole thing is perfectly legal
the law does require the government to
give you fair value for your property
but the bureaucrats decide what fair
value is mrs. Kealey I have great news
they've agreed to increase their offer
by $10,000 so that kilo didn't want the
money she wanted to keep her home but
the government said no so the bulldozers
came 90 families left Suzette and six
others refused to leave while this was
going on I interviewed the real-life
Kela we were backed into corners like
animals in a corner I gave the city's
lawyer a hard time about that any group
of politicians can kick you out of your
home well that's true but that's true if
you want to put up a road for example
the question is is this serving an
important public purpose and we say it
is it's giving him a lot of power
yes that's true a libertarian law firm
the Institute for justice took Suzette's
case all the way to the US Supreme Court
or Justice Sandra Day O'Connor pushed
back against the taking see you had a
motel 6 and the city says well if we had
a ritz-carlton we would have hired
now is that okay yes your honor that
would be okay so you can take from a to
give to B if B pays more taxes if it is
a significant amount yes Suzette's
lawyer responded this way the one thing
that all poor neighborhood share is that
they don't produce much tax revenue if
the court affirms the lower court's
decision then he would put poor
neighborhoods and working-class
neighborhoods like Fort Trumbull in
jeopardy he was right but the Supreme
Court rolled five to four against
suzette US Supreme Court today affirmed
the power of local governments to seize
private property the decision alarmed
people across America some states passed
laws limiting their politicians right to
grab your property in New London people
rallied around Suzette
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for you all for fighting so hard
but that fight was over they'd lost
years later I went with siz that kilo de
look at the place New London said was
going to be a booming development this
is my stairs and I had a lung for CH and
this is where husbands the city said
they had to tear the houses down because
development would happen tax revenues
all kinds of cool new things and yet
this is what they got no hotel or
upscale housing no conference centre no
nothing kilos house has been torn down
and a lot word once stood is vacant
it's still empty even today 13 years
later there's no development it's just
unused land the politicians were wrong
this new movie is a good reminder of
just how powerful and wrong politicians
often are